okay let's see what else we've got going
on here
let's go to Ari who usually asks about
Iran or Russia what's going on Ari
III David I guess it's given your
description after sort of live up to my
moniker so uh actually I was can ask you
about the molar report and as it
pertains to Russia actually because you
mentioned it um so it seems like it as
the cause obviously some sort of schism
among liberals and even you know I would
say some of your colleagues sort of come
down on it differently you know there's
the in this or the Matt cite the article
that Russia is this generation yeah or
whatever any despite the fact the full
report has not been released
um my question is do you think that
there I regardless of what if there's no
considering that there's no definitive
evidence yet and it you know he could
have perhaps you know he should be you
know Tom should be held to whatever
standard if he could collude or didn't
or whatever the situation but do you
think there was a you know like people
like you in the Young Turks I've been
covered it pretty rationally but there
was like a contingent of sort of the I
guess you could say the mainstream
corporate media that was sort of Tata
I would are just sort of a alarmist
attitudes regarding and and in terms of
like you know even I think Michael
Brooks who kind of comes down on the
same side it's John through under Russia
keeping sort of marks the whole you know
she always sort of brings up you know
these scenarios like you know Russia
could hack into our power but increased
you guys you know during the winter and
all this kind of event you think they
did you say she who'd that you've said
Michael Brooks and you said she did I
miss something
oh oh oh okay okay I missed that sorry
yeah yeah yes so it's like there's
almost there's sort of one on this
attitude that in it and kind of clouds
of the picture I think it's
counterproductive
despite the fact that he you know try a
very well even Callisto and we don't we
don't know it's not there yet so that
you think that there's some truth or any
young people like all took all the
things that we should be you know
attacking the Kremlin militarily I mean
there's an aspect that's you like re I'm
having trouble because it sounds like
there's gravel in your mouth I know it's
just a connection thing did you say
something about attacking the Kremlin
militarily I think yeah I do what I what
I mentioned was that Paul Begala are you
somebody yeah I know Paul I don't know
yeah yes yes mentioned something like
that for subsequent to the election
actually you know where you know it was
basically when all the stuff was first
coming out about the potential pollution
and I'm thinking that seems to be an
alarmist attitude that it has raised up
the situation for people and you know
just for most people are not going to
class some of the basic concepts so it
kind of it almost I think strategically
unfortunately plays in the hands of
trauma do you think that there's some
merit to what I'm saying in terms of
some people kind of going overboard on
their analysis yeah listen I mean okay
so let's let's take for example they
adjust my chair here apologize the
Rachel Maddow thing I've not seen like
I've seen one episode of Rachel Maddow
in the last two years and it was the one
where she was she supposedly had Trump's
tax return and it was like the first
page of his 1040 from three years ago or
something so I don't I don't really know
exactly what you're talking about but
there's no question that the the Donald
Trump narrative of no collusion no
obstruction whatever which of course is
based on bars political letter as I know
you know re that is fomented by
right-wing media but it's also fomented
by people who are just sensationalizing
or doing whatever you know I don't
always succeed but I've tried to be
clear that if the expectation is Trump
is personally colluding with Putin in a
proactive way that's not a good
expectation it's not that's not what's
going to be found
it's the chances are almost zero as I
said a year ago some of the stuff you're
describing I don't know anything about
but if people are suggesting attacking
the Kremlin I mean it sounds wacky but I
just haven't heard that a lot of
Americans that they don't understand
despite the fact that we should
obviously in for
our democracy in any way - and ourselves
in a way from any foreign powers typer
yep I agree with that are the
connections so bad I'm gonna let you go
but I do appreciate the call and you you
can call back again just sounds like
he's talking with a mouth full of rocks
I can't uh it's just it's not working
well not working well